the Chinese government is trying with
increasing ferocity to use its economic
and diplomatic clout to silence critical
voices abroad and to undermine global
institutions that protect human rights
China's obviously long censored critics
at home the government is now trying to
extend that censorship to the rest of
the world Oh Kenneth Rauf there
Hong Kong is just one of the focal
points of China's repression and
activists there saying Beijing is using
the territories police to enforce a
policy of ever greater brutality butts a
support for the Communist Party's line
among the police in Hong Kong is not
Universal some are risking their jobs or
worse by speaking out tws Matthias
Berliner filed this report
when David Chen joined the Hong Kong
police force a few years ago he never
thought that he would see scenes like
these David Chan is not his real name
this was last November when protesters
and police clashed for hours on a
university campus Hong Kong police had
come under massive attack
and david says it's not only the
physical threats that affect morale
they've been working long hours they've
been blamed fingers pointed at them it's
very exhausting both physically and
mentally this is what he's talking about
Hong Kong is criticizing and often
cursing at the police many officers are
on edge they've been accused of
indiscriminate arrests beating up
subdued protesters and threatening to
shoot tear gas into apartments videos of
alleged police brutality are circulating
online bystanders will get into
arguments with officers risk getting
pepper sprayed a clear violation of the
rules as David learned I'm just
frustrated because some officers really
dislike the protesters and honestly they
really want to beat them up but I think
this isn't the right mentality we should
be impartial as police officers we
shouldn't take sides
he says he's currently doing as much as
100 hours of overtime every month while
he isn't serving at the frontline as
backup he often has to be at the site of
demonstrations David is hiding his
identity for fear of being bullied by
protesters online and he worries about
professional repercussions as a member
of the Hong Kong police force
I shouldn't be criticizing it in public
but as a citizen of Hong Kong I have to
say the senior officers have basically
messed it up
officials deny the police have done
anything wrong the police has been in
the focus of the demonstrators since
June when they first violently broke up
a protest since then public anger has
steadily grown especially among the
young David says most of his friends
have turned that back on him in the past
six month I was a bit upset about it
because they were my good friends but
then I thought about it there's nothing
I can do he says several of his
colleagues have quit their jobs but
while he's at odds with the current
tactics he has no intention to leave I
should be staying in the police force
and tried to maintain the right
mentality and to uphold the values of
the police it's a tough challenge for
David stuck between loyalty and doubt
let's go now straight to Beijing and DWS
Matthias Bolinger for more about that
new Human Rights report about China
oppressions oppression and a suppression
of human rights good day to you Matias
can you fill us in on some of the
reports details that shows China working
for quote dystopian future at home and
abroad well we have just seen one
example of China's repression which is
Hong Kong where human rights
organizations have accused China and
Hong Kong police and Hong Kong
government that is dependent on China of
restricting the previously quite liberal
freedoms of the city there are of course
the very grim examples of the
suppression of we goes where we are
seeing the biggest internment of an
ethnic group probably since the end of
World War two and the massive
surveillance state that has been
installed in the singeing region but
increasingly also throughout China we
have seen increasing arrests during the
past few years of human rights activists
wide use torture etc a church
cetera all this is not new what the
report now details about is the
mechanisms the China is using to
suppress criticism abroad outside of
China this is probably the most
disturbing part of the report certainly
for people abroad where does Human
Rights Watch consider China's threat to
human rights overseas most severe is
their specific area well one of the
groups for example that have really
really been targeted are the weekers
abroad they have been threatened abroad
they have been threatened their their
their family members have disappeared
and there all of this was used to
suppress their criticism Chiney groups
of pro-government supporters have been
mobilized for example on universities
across the world to counter protests
against China's human rights record and
there have has also been pressure on the
human rights mechanisms the
International Human Rights mechanisms as
well as on countries that are
financially dependent on China to
support China's oppression policies for
example in Shenyang ok now this report
also says that China's leadership is
quote scared of its own people is that
the sense that you have from your time
reporting in China Brian this is a very
tough question because we need to be
careful with public opinion in China we
do not have any service we know that
there all kinds of opinions exists and
but we do not really know to what extent
they are represented in the population
what we have seen however and this is
something that I would support that
whatever news are leaked whenever there
have been investigative reports and
there have been more in the past when
press control was less strict about
abuses of power
public reaction immediately is there and
the the the the public anger builds up
very quickly so what I think what we can
clearly say is that this system of
governance in China would not be able
the power of the Communist Party would
definitely not survive in the way it is
exercised now without this massive
repression and this massive censorship
DWS Matthias Berliner Matthias thanks so
very much for bringing us up-to-date on
this new report